[Musique]
on dit souvent qu'on printemps on
assiste à une explosion de vie
aujourd'hui on vous propose de plonger
dans un écosystème inusité celui des
mares éphémère la faune exubérante qui
grouillent a de quoi surprendre et
mérite qu'on la protège
[Musique]
cette salamandre est à peine sorti de sa
torpeur hivernale qu'elle entreprend
déjà sa migration printanière
elle cherche lieux bien précis pour se
reproduire un écosystème inusité créé
uniquement par la fonte des neiges
lamarre éphémères chaque printemps les
mains éphémères sont le théâtre de
curieux spectacle
[Musique]
bien que le fonds unique dépendent de
ces milieux les morts éphémères sont
parmi les écosystèmes les plus menacées
de nos forêts
[Musique]
puis ces naturalistes bénévoles font en
mission ils vont dresser l'inventaire
complet de l'étang de saint marcellin
près de rimouski cet étang est à ce jour
la plus importante marée fait mais
reconnu au bas saint laurent
à première vue l'endroit a plutôt l'air
de lacq mais aucun cours d'eau
n'alimente cette cuvette
elle se remplit uniquement par la fonte
des neiges
ça ça va s'assécher presque complètement
finalement en juillet ça va être d'une
apparence très différentes il va avoir
une végétation qui va pousser dans le
fond de l'étang
on reconnaîtra plus l'état on va voir se
déprécier
[Applaudissements]
voici le même endroit en étaient les
temps a complètement disparu
[Musique]
ou que les espèces de poissons ne peut
survivre ici voilà pourquoi au printemps
les salamandres recherche ces milieux
leur jeu se développeront à l'abri des
prédateurs
[Applaudissements]
walter bertha qui est un retraité du
ministère de la faune du québec
il cherche à faire reconnaître la valeur
de ces milieux exceptionnel encore trop
peu connue au bout de son filet non une
femme discrète pendant quelques semaines
walter profitera d'une concentration
inouïe d'espèces au même endroit que je
pense que j'ai de quoi ici voilà qu'est
ce que c'est je dirais que de ce que
j'ai vu avec le spot c'est une salle à
mende maculé donc c'est une des deux
espèce de salamandre qu'on dit
fouisseuses c'est une des espèces
indicatrices d'ailleurs des dés et
entend par là et des étendards
on sait peu compliqué le poly d'affilée
les points jaunes que l'on voit sur la
salamandre
ça laisse peu de place à la rage et ça
c'est pas une espèce qui est rare
ces parts
zen qu'elles vont se regrouper dans des
états sur ces images on aperçoit un
groupe de salamandre maculé
principalement des morts on pense qu'ils
s'adonneraient à une parade nuptiale
pour séduire une femelle la reproduction
des salamandres durera deux à trois
semaines après cette période mâles et
femelles quitteront la barre pour
regagner la terre ferme
[Musique]
voici l'autre salamandre fouisseuses la
salamandre à point bleu elle dépend elle
aussi des morts éphémère pour se
reproduire
les naturalistes ont également dénombré
quantité de grenouilles des bois et de
reinette crucifères c'est d'ailleurs
cette dernière que vous entendez en
toile de fond
les marais fener abrite aussi une
kyrielle d'insectes voici la rana brune
on voit ici
vingt autres invertébrés aquatiques
est ce que c'est un prédateur est un
beau spécimen s'est énormément riches
même s'ils sont en parler même si ça
sert c'est fou la vie qui a la taille
[Musique]
de nuit comme de jour ces bénévoles
fouilles s'est éteint depuis trois ans
et leur travail donne des résultats
l'étang de saint marcellin est
aujourd'hui un des premiers étant
temporaire à obtenir une protection
régionales en fait chez pas combien de
produits
mais comme ces écosystèmes sont méconnus
cet autre chercheur à la retraite ont dû
faire preuve de pédagogie pour
convaincre les élus on commence avec les
temporaires c'est plus facile à
comprendre puis éventuellement quand on
décrit ce kyodo puis la richesse
l'importance que ça peut avoir pour la
foire et les gens vivent beaucoup de la
forêt dans la région
ma légendaire finalement à sopi en font
un objet de fierté
[Musique]
non
mais il faudra plus qu'une
reconnaissance municipal pour conserver
ces milieux l'avenir de ces écosystèmes
pourrait passer par la foresterie
cerveau voire de l'érable et de l'érable
rouge de l'épinette blanche boulons jour
sébastien nadeau et biologiste il a
convaincu des propriétaires de forêts
privées de conserver des marges éphémère
plutôt que de les drainer
mais la nature temporaire de ces étangs
compliquer son travail
le manque de relever est aussi une
lacune en n'ayant pas de cartographie on
sait pas ou ce qu'ils sont faites les
propriétaires peuvent pour savoir ils
savent ils sont même pas au courant que
c'est des milieux qui sont d'une extrême
richesse et qu'il y aura un grand rôle à
jouer à l'échelle d'une propriété
forestière donc en ne sachant pas où ils
sont on n'est pas en mesure d'intervenir
les conseillers foresti qui donne les
services aux propriétaires de lots
boisés
mais eux ils savent pas que ça existe
parce que quand ils vont faire la
prescription silicon valley plus tôt
[Musique]
des écosystèmes uniques at on dit
regardez bien ceux ci
voici la créature la plus étrange de ces
milieux
à crevettes éphémère elles mesurent à
peine 20 mm de longueur
on la retrouve uniquement dans les mares
printanière
l'été en pleine sécheresse les yeux de
cette crevette s'enkyste dans la vase et
attendre la prochaine fonte des neiges
pour se développer
la crevette éphémère dépend entièrement
de ce cycle saisonnier pour survivre à
des effets mais a retrouvé dans un état
ils se qualifient automatiquement comme
un étang vernal deux valeurs
[Musique]
certains états américains ont déjà pris
des mesures réglementaires pour protéger
ces milieux
mais au québec beaucoup de travail reste
à faire
les marques fumeurs n'ont aucune
reconnaissance légale
toutefois le ministère de la faune du
québec vient d'amorcer un vaste
programme d'inventaire quelques jours
ont passé et les salamandres ont
maintenant accrocher leur ceux sur les
moindre brindille
ils pompent pas toujours d'un couple ont
accroché un peu on accroche et ailleurs
ça peut être des petits paquets une
course s'est engagée l'assèchement de la
mare guette désormais c'est eux
il faut que le qui sortent de la masse
pour commencer et ensuite que les larves
grandissent grossistes ils vont voir
leurs branchies et puis rendu après deux
à trois mots là ce moment alors elles
vont être prête à se transformer elles
vont résorber leurs branchies et elles
vont pouvoir tranquillement pas vite
ressortir sur la terre ferme finalement
et leur prendre leurs intérêts
[Musique]
les marges des fumeurs au jusqu'ici
échappé aux mailles de la conservation
pourtant près de la moitié des 21
espèces d'amphibiens au québec dépend de
ces milieux pour se reproduire
en attendant les actions de l'état
walter bertha qui continuera de ratisser
les mares de sa région
pour lui la conservation débute toujours
par une connaissance des milieux à
protéger
on a encore beaucoup de travail à faire
mais on sent qu'ils ont tu as toi tu es
avance plus ça va aboutir
des actions qui a des résultats qui vont
être sexuel
[Musique]